[Musique]
l'entretien politique avec françois de
mazières maire de versailles bonjour
bonjour alors vous avez été réélu
largement d'ailleurs dès le premier tour
comme maire de versailles c'est votre
troisième mandat à la tête de cette
ville
évidemment c'est un mandat dont le début
est affecté par la crise sanitaire dans
cette ville qui est aussi et surtout une
capitale mondiale du tourisme et donc ça
pose des vrais problèmes
justement on a beaucoup parlé du rôle
essentiel des élus et des élus locaux
dans cette lutte que dans la crise
sanitaire
quel est votre rôle à la fois pour
protéger la population évidemment et et
aussi pour gérer cette crise sanitaire
c'est pendant la période du confinement
on était vraiment situation très
particulière parce que on était au four
et au moulin il fallait s'occuper des
masques
il fallait aussi rassuré trouver les
moyens de communiquer tout même avec la
population et c'est vrai que les
nouveaux moyens et mis les moyens
audiovisuels a été très utile de
communiquer par les réseaux sociaux et
puis il fallait aussi tout simplement
rassurer les minimums service public
donc tout ça nous a pris beaucoup de
temps à ça c'était une période très
particulière assez épuisant pour tout le
monde dans un policer rien dit également
évidemment pour les services et qui
tournait autour de la médecine est
médecin ou un pôle majeur infirmiers
l'hôpital a connu une période
extrêmement difficile
puis là on est dans une période où on
est dans la suite et la suite c'est
notamment les problématiques économiques
pendant la paire de confinement on avait
dû fermer un certain nombre d'activités
c'était des décisions d'ailleurs
préfectoral est là maintenant et on
essaye de faire en sorte que tout se
passe au mieux pour l'ensemble des
activités la ville
on a aussi le souci des facilités parce
que c'est très compliqué aujourd'hui les
tests covin sachant que ces tests sont
faits par des laboratoires privés et que
même grande difficulté mais alors
justement il ya quand on est un décideur
politique quand on donne un maire il ya
il ya un obstacle terrible c'est
l'incertitude est on est on a
l'impression qu'on est dans une période
d'incertitude comment on arrive
justement à gérer à prendre des
décisions dans cette période où rien
n'est certain
même les scientifiques ce ne sont pas
tous d'accord entre eux d'ailleurs ce
que certains section de on a peu de
possibilités de projection sur le moyen
long terme est vraiment obligé de réagir
impôts jour le jour en fonction de
l'actualité
d'abord parce qu'il ya des gens qui se
trouve soudain dans la nécessité de
s'isoler
parce que l'on était en présence d'une
personne qui a été testée coville parce
que eh bien les sujets sont tous les
jours aux différents que ce soit sur le
plan économique du commerce
donc voilà on est par rapport à un
schéma habituel
on est plus sur du court terme que sur
le moyen long alors la ville de
versailles
il y avait un classement qui a été fait
par le point qui voudraient c'était une
des villes les mieux gérées de france il
ya peu de dettes qu'il y ait une
fiscalité modérée mais c'est aussi je le
disais c'est une capitale du tourisme
et évidemment ce tourisme été affectés
par la crise de l'aco vide
est-ce que vous pouvez déjà estimé un
peu des pertes qui sont qui sont ceux de
la ville et qui sont ceux aussi de 2 de
l'économie de versailles eyes
alors on essaie imminent immédiatement
suivie de voir quelle était la perte
notamment d'ailleurs pour les services
de ma vie on estime nous la perte
financière pour la ville versait à un
peu plus de 8 millions d'euros et encore
ces chiffres on doit les ajuster en
permanence
c'est une carte extrêmement importante
pour nous totalement inhabituel après il
y a vivement les pertes pour l'ensemble
des activités touristiques les hôtels et
restaurants
ça c'est quasiment un chiffre à
aujourd'hui
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
dans une ville qui est une ville centre
comme nous est particulièrement élevé un
exemple simplement les recettes du
parking qui sont devant le château
c'est les recettes importantes 3
millions d'euros jusqu'à présent elles
sont perçues dans la ville de versailles
bien que le château de versailles
souhaite aujourd'hui les récupérer mais
donc jusqu'à ce jour c'est nous qui
percevront 3 millions d'euros vous voyez
c'est l'équivalent d'à peu près six
points d'impôts donc c'est vous dire à
quel point ces des conséquences très
importantes pour nous ce plan financier
est très lourde et et tout ça dans un
danger dans une heure un environnement
qui est celui de du désengagement de
l'état vis-à-vis des des collectivités
locales alors il ya ce phénomène de
désengagement qu'on voit depuis quelques
années il ya en même temps ce plan de
relance qui était de 200 milliards est
ce que les villes comme versailles vont
bénéficier justement de ce plan de
relance alors ciblé c'est certain que
l'état est confronté à des dépenses
aujourd'hui vertigineuse les villes ne
sont pas les mieux traités loin de là
parce que si je prends l'exemple de
versailles
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui reçu aux
cordes n il est annoncé un certain
nombre de soutiens mais de toutes les
façons les pertes par exemple les pertes
de recettes du biel ne sont pas prises
en compte en haut le sait d'ores et déjà
voyez ce que c'est cette ville sont très
nombreux sont les recettes de piscine ce
sont des recettes de des maisons cartier
et tout ça finalement c'est très lourd
et en face nous avons maintenu les
salaires prenons le cas des animateurs
dans nos écoles nous avons beaucoup
d'animateurs qui permettent notamment de
garder les enfants un peu plus tard le
soir ou les gardes à la pause américaine
ses amis nateur où on avait la
possibilité juridique mots de cesser
leur rémunération
mais on n'a pas voulu faire parce que
eux-mêmes et aidé en difficulté très
content tout ça pèse sur les finances
habile et en face c'est pas les recettes
habituelles puisque généralement vous
fait payer les familles sur les autres
entre guillemets garderait alors bon
évidemment il ya cet environnement qui
est le disait un certain qui est plutôt
un peu noir est difficile évidemment
mais bon ça n'empêche que vous êtes
quand même aussi à la tête d'une des
villes les plus merveilleuses de france
alors peut-être pour finir sur une note
un peu plus positive
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter aux
versailles et de versailles et qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez vous aux versaillais
ce dirt vers soyez chose qu'on peut
souhaiter c'est que vous trouver une
solution à cette pandémie
c'est vrai que voir encore aujourd'hui
en ce mois d'octobre des incertitudes on
a envie qu'elle soit des reines première
chose qu'on peut souhaiter c'est que on
retrouve une situation normale et qui en
situation normale sous plan sanitaire on
est une situation normale son plan
économique le plan social là que l'on
puisse revient dans les terrade que l'on
puisse revenir dans l'école de sport
sans appréhension c'est ça que l'on peut
souhaiter aux gens et bien merci
beaucoup
françois de wazières java vous êtes
maire de versailles et à très vite
j'espère sur tv 78 merci beaucoup